la situation pour le mi6 avait je dirais
que avec l'éthique et la foule en
tulle et crac dernières semaines on a eu
deux semaines
très chargée au moyen ne faisait cinq
animations
par semaine sympa semaine on est passé à
5 pages où
on est resté à l'hôpital pendant quinze
jours confinés à l'hôpital
endurer amené à l'urgence les ambulances
arrivé tout les sens
être poêle à frire à jour avec soin
c'est quoi notre propre pays
[Musique]
donc ça devient un petit peu un peu
lourd à porter parce que mon les
familles sont complètement des composés
d orienter et ça plus vraiment se dire
qu'ils savent réussi puisqu'il ya dans
la peur d'être abandonné